So as many of you may or may not have seen
there appears to be an ongoing crisis within the British Labour Party
in relation to the parties
stance on the current conflict between Israel and Palestine
With Labour leader
Keri Starmer’s
general stance on this so far
being that Israel has a right to defend themselves
it is of course
worth noting that he did come out yesterday
stating that the humanitarian situation in Gaza is currently insufficient while
still refraining from a more explicit condemnation of Israel's current policy
of course as many of you will also be aware
there's also several Labour politicians
who've kind of disagreed with Starmer’s stance on the situation
such as the mayor of London
Sadiq Khan and Anas Sarwar
the Labour leader in Scotland
who've both called for an immediate ceasefire
probably the most outspoken figure on this topic
being the former Labour Party leader
Jeremy Corbyn
was actually suspended from the Labour Party a few years ago
due to anti semitism charges
with many people believing
after several inquiries
that it was actually Corbyn’s position on this conflict
that led to those accusations of anti Semitism
but with this in mind
we'll have to see if the current Labour Party policy
on the Israel Palestine situation remains the same
with the current divide in the party over it